clubic sénart et le centre national du
livre présente livres et vous
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans livres et vous
vous avez sans doute comme mes invités
comme moi comme tout le monde
deux bonnes raisons de vous révolter du
blocage des universités à la défense de
la zad des violences des black blocks
jusqu aux expéditions des migrants des
soucis quotidiens jusqu'au rêve de
destruction du système en général at on
raison de se révolter et dans quel but
mais deux invités aujourd'hui ne sont
d'accord sur rien et surtout pas sur la
question de la révolte en 2015 pierre
manent faisait paraître situation de la
france dans lequel le philosophe
appréhender l'islam comme un problème
auquel les solutions proposées avait
fait couler beaucoup d'encre il fait
paraître ce mois ci la loi naturelle et
les droits de l'homme dans lequel la
critique porte cette fois sur le recours
systématique aux droits comme moteur des
revendications et des actions en général
pierre manent nous rejoindra en deuxième
partie d'émission on première invitée
est également philosophe mais ils en
appellent à davantage de révoltes et
peut-être même à la révolution
la réponse à la question du jour se
trouve dans le titre de son dernier
livre on a raison de se révolter
il est avec nous aujourd'hui pour en
parler dans livrez-vous bonjour alain
badiou bonjour bienvenue dans ce lieu le
plus heureux d'y être
votre parcours universitaire et brillant
vous êtes ancien élève de l'école
normale supérieure major à l'agrégation
de philosophie vous avez enseigné en
lycée à l'université de reims elle était
professeur à l'école normale supérieure
vous avez publié de nombreux essais de
philosophie une philosophie politique de
théâtre qui sont reconnus en france et
l'ue dans le monde entier
quelles raisons avez vous de vous
révolter les raisons de se révolter vous
savez ne sont pas forcément des raisons
extrêmement lisible dans une biographie
un peu courtes comme celle que vous
faites qui est au fond limité à ma
trajectoire intellectuelle et académique
je pense surtout que les raisons de se
révolter il faut en discuter en effet le
livre dit on a raison de se révolter
mais il conclut qu on a raison de se
révolter sous certaines conditions
c'est il ne prétend pas que n'importe
quelle forme de révolte soit eux
admissible ou même glorieuses on a
raison de se révolter parce que le monde
est ce qu'il est en dernier ressort et
donc je pense que les raisons de se
révolter aujourd'hui il faut les
chercher quand même dans l'effet
d'aubaine frappant de ce monde l'errance
de millions et de millions de personnes
à la recherche d'un lieu pour vivre qui
prend ici la forme du problème des
migrants comme une espèce de mer qui
bavent autres rivages protéger la
question des inégalités monstrueuse qui
existe dans cette planète la culture
d'un développement économique livrée pas
en vérité à une religion est extrêmement
restreinte
on peut essayer quand même de se
révolter contre tout ça mais la révolte
était la meilleure réponse à ces
situations qui finalement vous décrivez
une situation contemporaine
mais depuis le début de l'histoire de
l'humanité l'homme avait de bonnes
raisons de se révolter
oui ils essaient d'ailleurs constamment
révoltés après tout et les révoltes ont
jalonné l'histoire de l'humanité à
prendre même à un temps assez court de
la révolte des esclaves sous la
direction de spartacus aux émeutes les
plus récentes
il y a un fils historique delà de la
révolte et la révolte ne s'est pas avéré
nécessairement et puis centre de toute
évolution française a aussi commencé par
un certain nombre de refus et de
révoltes et les révolutions du xxème
siècle qu'était le riche ont aussi
commencé dans les mêmes conditions et
mai 68 puisqu'on en fête l'anniversaire
c'était aussi largement une dimension de
révolte qui animait en tout cas les
participants l'immédiat de la chose vous
ne distinguez par yves révolte de
révolution si je distingue actuellement
révolte de révolution mais vous savez le
mot révolte reste relativement clair il
a un volt quand des groupes ou des
personnes se lèvent pour déclarer leur
indignation au regard de ce qui leur
arrive et du monde tel qu'il est et les
révoltes au fond quelque chose de
spontané
parfois d'inattendu c'est à dire m e mai
68 était quelque chose tout à fait
inattendue par rapport à une situation
prospère de plein emploi
sans les problèmes que nous avons
aujourd'hui c'est bon et donc je pense
que les révoltes c'est un élément assez
clair assez constant c'est naturel
d'ailleurs la citation complète de noël
c'est comme si on a raison de se
révolter contre les réactionnaires donc
c'était un contre la révolte c'est une
négation et révolution est devenu avons
beaucoup plus compliqué parce que la
révolution elle ajoute à la révolte
un élément qui lui nécessairement
créateurs ou affirmatif dire la
révolution c'est le passage d'un ordre
du monde à un autre ordre du monde ça
n'est pas simplement une levée qui peut
être éventuellement dramatique ou
festivals et 2 contre l'état des choses
les listes et pensez vous qu'aujourd'hui
le contexte actuel que vous avez dénoncé
la révolte la meilleure réponse la seule
façon de faire changer la situation ou
bien est ce un constat que vous
appliquez un mai 68 uniquement auquel
vous avez consacré votre ouvrage je
pense que je pense que les révoltes sont
toujours nécessaires ça ne veut pas dire
qu'elle soit la meilleure ou la réponse
idéale aux situations dans le monde
m'est arrivé quand un ordre est imposé à
une énorme masse de gens cette énorme
masse de gens qui n'ont pas accès en
tant que tel aux mécanismes du pouvoir
aux mécanismes de l'ordre économique etc
s'ils veulent déclarer leur indignation
et non pour eux que leur nombre et leur
discipline finalement ils n'ont ni
d'argent ni l'armée ni la police ni les
formes politiques qui sont celles au
service de l'ordre dominant et donc la
révolte et en un certain sens à moteur
inéluctable de l'histoire je suis
d'accord en ce sens avec la formule
selon laquelle ce sont les masses qui
font l'histoire en dernier ressort de
son nez les héros ni même les
institutions ce sont les masses et donc
au niveau des masses nous avons
nécessairement si le monde doit changer
nous l'avons ceci et s'est appuyé cette
formule que
que constituent les révoltes mais en un
certain sens les révoltes ouvre le
problème elle déchire la situation mais
ne produisent pas par elle-même
la substitution désiré d'un ordre un
autre alors on appelait cette
substitution désiré datant d'un autre
révolution révolution ou fonds est un
beau qui a désigné de façon assez
précise
leur placement d'une formule de pouvoir
par une autre la prise de pouvoir
insurrectionnel révolutionnaire qu'au
fond le moment révolutionnaire le plus
intense et puis après le remplacement de
ce pouvoir par un autre pouvoir du
pouvoir monarchique du pouvoir
républicain du pouvoir bourgeois et
capitaliste par un pouvoir prolétariat
et communiquent mais ça c'est une autre
paire de manches parce que vous n'êtes
plus là dans les conséquences
nécessaires de la négativité révoltez
vous avez à construire un monde alors il
ya eu pendant tout le xxème siècle une
formule la destruction porte la
construction on faisait confiance au
fond au mouvement de destructions pour
donner les indications les lignes de
conduite de la construction je crois que
le bilan du xxème siècle c'est que ce
n'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
c'est à dire d'une certaine manière la
destruction porte la destruction aux
tons et les moyens qui ont été ceux de
la destruction continue à être les
moyens de la construction en
l'occurrence la la violence la
coercition la la terreur et donc il faut
maintenant se rendre compte que dit le
début du processus proprement politique
nous devons déjà être dans une certaine
représentation de ce que sera la
construction ne faut pas simplement crié
à bas ce qui existe c'est à dire que la
fin ne justifie pas tous les moyens le
dire en d'autres termes c'est surtout
qu'il faut savoir de quels faits il
s'agit précisément de la lisibilité de
la fin alors mal à se révolter les
raisons ne manquent pas mais pour aller
vers ou et vers quoi et bien précisément
c'est le cas de l'analyse des séquences
successives
de l'état du monde si vous êtes dans un
état monarchique ça veut dire que vous
devez réfléchir longuement à ce que
c'est qu'un état non monarchique
positivement donc est ce que c'est
qu'une république qu'est ce que c'est
que la représentation républicaine le
travail des gens de rousseau qui conçoit
que à la place du breuil narc on doit
avoir une assemblées délibératives qui
prend les décisions et c'est alors nous
notre problème n'est pas exactement
celui de la formule politique de l'état
notre problème est celui du
bouleversement de l'ordre économique
dominant et donc il faut aussi se
demander qu'est ce que c'est qu'une
gestion collective des moyens de
production et nous savons aujourd'hui
c'est un enseignement nouveau et
important que remettre tout cela aux
mains d'un nouvel état dirigiste n'est
pas la solution
parce qu'en réalité cet état ne réalise
pas une véritable appropriation
collective des moyens de production
ils organisent au fond leur
appropriation par un personnel limité
qu'est le personnel de l'état ou du
parti qu'il devienne la même chose donc
là là et c'est là que nous en sommes de
notre réflexion et les révoltes qui
viennent et qui se poursuivent ont d'une
manière ou d'une autre devrons peut se
nourrir de ses enseignements
exactement comme tout au long du xviiie
siècle les révoltes paysannes anarchique
se sont progressivement nourrit des
idées des lumières au 19e siècle les
idées de la révolte spontanée sauvage
des ouvriers se sont finalement nourrit
de la pensée marxiste et bien
aujourd'hui nous devons nourrir dans la
deuxième phase des révolte anti
capitaliste nous devons faire le même
travail
on l'aura compris alain badiou en
parallèle à votre métier de professeur
de philosophie vous menez un combat
politique qu'on peut qualifier de
communiste en 1969 vous participez à la
création l'union des communistes de
france marxiste léniniste ucf groupe
bah oui dont vous restait l'un des
principaux dirigeants jusque dans au
début des années 1980 comment cette
activité politique militante est elle
compatible avec votre métier de
philosophe
vous savez je crois que la philosophie
est une discipline qui
suppose des conditions dans la vision
glanait on voit très bien que platon
lui-même n'aurait pas existé s'il
n'avait pas eu les mathématiques grec
kke avaient été fondés bien avant lui
s'il n'avait pas été en discussion avec
la figure démocratique de l'état
athéniens qu'il contestait s'il n'avait
pas eu d expérience extrêmement
difficiles avec les tyrans cixi l'état
et par ailleurs il était aussi un
spectateur de tragédie et toute une
partie de son discours concerne
finalement qu'est ce que sont les
émotions esthétiques et a donc j'ai
proposé de venir que la philosophie à
quatre conditions en quatre registres de
conditions plutôt les chances bien
entendu l'activité artistique et puis
les formes de la politique et puis
l'amour en tant que dimension proprement
existentielle déjà repéré par platon
dans le banquet où il dit expressément
que sur deux jambes étaient amoureux
peut pas être philosophe
ce sont les quatre jalons de votre
oeuvre d'ailleurs allemagne au mexique
le théâtre la politique et l'amour
absolument se sont se sont donc montés à
mon travail de philosophe est axée sur
les quatre conditions et au fond ces
quatre conditions elles ont comme
caractéristique depuis toujours que vous
ne pouvez pas les connaître et rudiments
abstraitement et à la philosophie
nourrit d'engagement existentielle
spécifié diversifiée il faut quand même
connaître un peu de science et non pas
rien du tout il faut savoir qu est ce
que c est un peu que l'art contemporain
et et pas l'ignorer entièrement il faut
savoir ce que c'est que la relation
absolue à un autre dans l'élément de
l'amour en avoir fait l'expérience il
faut aussi avoir pratiqué certaines
figures de l'engagement politique
donc mon métier de philosophes
n'existerait même pas s'il n'y avait pas
en effet c'est ces figures existentielle
et pourtant le métier de philosopher
d'un côté de définir les
et dans une lignée platonicienne vous
l'avez cité la notion même d'idées très
importante dans votre travail mais de
l'autre aussi de toujours remettre en
question ce que l'on tient pour évident
cette mise en question se doute qu'elle
propre de la philosophie n'est-il pas
incompatible avec un engagement
idéologique vous êtes communiste vous
avez été maoïste ce sont des engagements
très forts au nom d'une idée qui
n'accepte aucune incertitude mais l'idée
que la philosophie se nourri
d'incertitudes de doute une idée pauvres
tout de même elle n'est pas confirmée
par l'histoire de la philosophie est
encore en laissant des la philosophie
quand même c'était courant de la
philosophie faible c'est même un courant
de ce que j'appelle moi lentilles
philosophie est une dimension interne à
la philosophie mais qu'elle a philosophé
qui prétend faire l'économie des notions
cardinal de la philosophie qui sont
qu'est ce que l'être
qu'est ce que la vérité qu'est ce que la
justice etc en vérité le grand massif
philosophique depuis toujours que ce
soit platon que ce soit des cartes que
ce soit eagle que ce soit sartre que ce
soit et ailleurs etc
ce grand massif de la philosophie et ne
pratiquent pas le doute comme finalité
ils pratiquent éventuellement le doute
locales sur tel ou tel concept est
irritée dans la tradition philosophique
mais le doigt personne qui se soit
nourri philosophiquement du doute d'un
bout à l'autre qu'il soit devenu un
grand philosophe et la remise en
question ce sont les dialogues
platoniciens que nous avons mais les
délais étaient déjà cette affaire berner
tout à fait en état de voir que les
dialogues surtout à partir du milieu de
la philosophie de platon porte des
conclusions quand même extrêmement
ambitieuse et j'ai écrit un écrit un
petit livre sur wildenstein on peut
penser que vous lui même n'est pas du
tout quelqu'un qui doute et il a au
contraire à la fois une férocité
critique considérable consulte mais ne
lui plaît pas et il a des affirmations
spectaculairement affirmative
dans votre livre on a raison de se
révolter vous proposer une analyse de
mai 68 en disant qu'il s'est vraiment
passé quelque chose d'important à ce
moment là on en parle beaucoup de mai 68
1 depuis un mois vous faites partie de
ceux qui pensent qu'on devrait en parler
même davantage car dites vous à sa
manière mai 68 a déclaré que la vie sans
idée était insupportable c'est à dire
que mai 68 avait cette particularité de
nous proposer une idée à suivre pour
comme un chemin que nous pourrions
suivre pour changer
de monde c'est ça je crois que mai 68
est resté un événement énigmatique
jusqu'à aujourd'hui jamais prétendu moi
même restreint d'états de l'élucider
complètement ils étaient dix matic parce
que il a été la composition de
mouvements extrêmement différents la
grande grève ouvrière la plus grande
grèves ouvrières de l'histoire de france
un soulèvement étudiant qui lui était
plutôt mondial qui se produisait aussi
au mexique ou des etats-unis dire en
chine etc ou en allemagne
et puis un courant idéologique visant la
transformation des moeurs dans une
vision plutôt libertaire ou anarchisante
tout ça à composer à mai 68 et le mot
composition est tout à fait nécessaire
ça n'a pas été du tout y de lever
unifiée dans des slogans commun etc des
tendances politiques très divertissant
affronter aussi bien du côté des
révolutionnaires que du côté des
centristes et des modérés républicain et
donc il ya une énigme de la complexité
de 1072 ceci dit je pense que ce qui est
certain c'est que l'idée commune le
mouvement était de se dégager de quelque
chose de ce qui était en train de se
mettre en place à savoir une société
dans laquelle ou d'une certaine façon
les deux identités dominante que la
masse des gens peuvent occuper comme
place dans la société sont premièrement
l'identité de salariés et de démos
l'identité de consommateurs alors on a
dit que c'était une révolte contre la
société de consommation et que c'était
aussi dans l'usiné d'une révolte contre
les conditions du travail mais ça c'est
la version limitée la chose je pense que
plus profondément c'est suspect de deux
tandems comme ça le salarié
consommateurs a été critiquée mis sur la
scène publique comme quelque chose qu'on
devait détailler rodez d'autres dépasser
ou transformées parce que si vous êtes
salarié
ça veut dire que vous n'êtes que votre
travail vous sert à acquérir de l'argent
et si vous êtes consommateur ça veut
dire que cet argent sert à alimenter le
circuit commercial lui-même
donc vous êtes un transit monétaire le
sujet est un transit monétaire il
accumule de l'argentin qui salarient le
dépense en tant que consommateur et ça
je pense que c'était quand même un
indice subjectif une manière subjective
de se rendre compte que l'ordre du monde
dominé par un capitalisme qui devenait
ces années là une matrice fondamental
dans le monde entier ne pouvait pas être
accepté comme une maxime de vie c'est ça
que j'appelle l'idée l'idée c'est
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que c'est
qu'être un chérubin
qu'est ce qu'être humain dans une vision
qui ne l'acceptent pas qu'il ne suffit
pas du tandem du consommateur et du
salarié vous n'êtes pas simplement
contrôler capitalisme vous êtes contre
la démocratie
vous qualifiez la démocratie
d'organisation du pouvoir hégémonique
dominant et vous dites la politique qui
existe le nom de démocratie n'est pas
démocratique du tout les gens n'ont
aucun pouvoir
oui mais vous vivez dans la formule les
conclu que que cette démographie n'est
pas démocratique nous vous le régime
démocratique platon ne le soutenait pas
non vieux jeu je pense que platon ne le
soutient pas mais un peu comme moi te
dire souhaitait pas ce qui ce qu'ils
avaient sous les yeux la démocratie
athénienne
enfin la démocratie athénienne nous
savons aujourd'hui cette étude
démocratie sans les esclaves sans les
étrangers sans les bettex en les
fadettes internet démocratie actuelle
c'est pas le cas de notre décor social
c'est pourquoi la critique de la
démocratie aujourd'hui ne peut pas être
la répétition de la critique de platon
c'est absolument envie d'écrire parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce que nous avons c'est
une nouvelle figure de la démocratie
qu'est la démocratie représentative et
démocratie représentative
inventé en fait par les anglais à la fin
du xviiie siècle a déjà été critiqué dès
le début par rousseau qui dans contrat
social explique qu'à ses yeux il n'y a
pas de démocratie du tout dans la figure
représentative parce que les conditions
d représentés sont des conditions qui
finalement sont homogènes au groupe
dominant et on le voit bien ici et tout
de même on le voit bien même quand la
gauche était au pouvoir elle capitule
nécessairement au bout d'un certain
temps dans l'idée qu'on ne peut pas
quand même transformé réellement la
machine général et les figures
subjective qui sont les siennes et dont
je parlais tout à l'heure que ce soit
mitterrand à partir de 83 que ce soit
lors d'un bout à l'autre que ce soit le
gouvernement jospin qui a des
nationalisées ou moins autant que que
ses prédécesseurs
la gauche parlementaire a montré c'est
pour ça qu'elle s'est écroulé d'ailleurs
récemment la gauche parlementaire a
montré qu'elle était hors d'état à
l'intérieur du système prétendument
démocratiques de changer la règle du jeu
qui règlent en fait les rapports entre
économie et politique
alors cette démocratie n'est pas
démocratique nouveau le peuple n'a pas
de pouvoir là dans ce cas du pouvoir
c'est les nécessités constamment invoqué
d'un ordre planétaire dominé par le
capitalisme mondialisé et on est
toujours en train de dire il faut payer
nos dettes
il faut restreindre le budget les
sécurité sociale ça coûte trop cher etc
etc
tout le monde le sait le peuple du
pouvoir là parce que c'est lui qui élit
ses représentants le peuple vote en
démocratie or vous êtes contre le vote
enfin vous milité en faveur de
l'abstention
je glisse contre le vote qui est une
manière antidémocratique de ronald ellis
contre ce vote là je n'oublie pas du
tout contre le vol d'une assemblée
générale pour savoir si on continue la
grève sur la côte est du pas et plus
généralement dans des démocraties qui
serait constitutif d'assemblées
populaires et edge désapprouveraient au
contraire comme disait lénine tout le
pouvoir aux soviets sais pas ce qui
s'est passé ensuite d'ailleurs été tout
voir au parti je suis d'accord mais lui
c'était pas son idée son idée c'était
tout le pouvoir aux assemblées
populaires qui se réunissent réellement
pour trancher les questions qui sont les
leurs et qui s'occupe aussi des
questions générales d'avoir la logique
actuelle de des démocraties occidentales
qui d'ailleurs sont en crise ces
démocraties
actuellement les exemples commune est ce
que vous prenez ont aussi était en crise
est bien situé mao tout à l'heure mao
c'est quand même 45 millions de morts
pendant la révolution culturelle et au
delà des chiffres et des xes même
quelques lots d'uchizy tik tok elle
aussi en tout anticommuniste que marcel
gauchet s'est mis d'accord avec moi sur
le chiffre de 700 milles au maximum au
grand maximum c'est un écart énorme
c'est comme la comptabilité des bodégas
manifeste dans une autre émission avec
quelqu'un que je ne citerai pas tout
d'un coup le dit oui mais les les 200
millions de morts en russie
c'est un chiffre absurde dure plus de
polio plus de ruches chez rue de chambly
mais ça c'est pas la question en fait la
question c'est celle de deux
d'utiliser comme l'exemple des peut-être
des modèles alors vous me direz ce sont
des modèles communiste vous cite ils
n'ont pas donné lieu à une chose paraît
très enviable ce qui a conduit ce qui a
suivi les révoltes et les révolutions
organes organisé par mao ou par staline
n'ont pas donné lieu à des choses très
très joyeux elles ont de détresse aux
yeux elles ont été dans leur phase
initiale c'est-à-dire en union
soviétique jusqu'à la fin des années 20
et en chine de façon beaucoup plus
disparates parce que les conditions
n'étaient pas les mêmes
elles ont donné lieu aux toutes
premières expérimentations de ce que
pouvait être un ordre social non soumis
à la loi du capitalisme
ces exemples ont échoué et je pense que
étant donné que le capitalisme à
plusieurs siècles et que ces exemples
ont duré 70 ans
c'est une comparaison un tout petit peu
boiteuse que vous faites là c'est pas le
même genre d'échec
d'un côté nous avons un échec d'un
système qui est au contraire de toute
évidence orienté vers sa propre fin le
capitaliste est évidemment la forme
suprême de ce qui s'est mis en place il
ya des milliers d'années dans les
sociétés de classe l'état des inégalités
monstrueuse
ddd impérialisme guerrier etc qui est au
fond la politique de l'ère néolithique
dont celle que quatre ou cinq mille ans
qui a commencé avec l'état égyptien
le nôtre près situation exactement la
même
il ya des inégalités monstrueuse il ne
faut pouvoir il ya des masses et
rentrent de deux pauvres et le cabinet
c'est la dernière forme de cela ça c'est
une chose contre cela
qu'est ce que nous avons nous avons 2 3
expérience limitée à quelques décennies
et on vient me dire oui mais ça il faut
et bien sûr que ça a échoué
bien sûr que ça a échoué pourquoi
pourquoi pourquoi des entreprises qui se
propose de sortir de quatre mille ans
d'histoire par des moyens que personne
ne connaît puisque nous en fassions la
gestion collective d'une économie ça n'a
jamais eu lieu
pourquoi trouverez qu'il la formule
miracle immédiatement bien sûr il y aura
des échecs il y en aura d'autres
encore faut-il soutenir le mouvement
général de cette sortie sinon autant
dire tout de suite
nous sommes très contents de ce qu'il ya
et puis c'est tout et pourquoi pas
ah mais pourquoi pas mais ça alors c'est
pas parce qu'à ce moment là ça veut dire
que la politique est sans idée
elle ne consiste tout simplement qu'à
suivre le fil des choses on peut
concevoir la politique comme de manière
moins idéaliste puisque vous parlez dit
l'importance de l'idée en politique
comme étant aussi le fameux delà de la
situation des livres le mieux possible
oui c'est bien supérieur mais le mieux
possible pour ça j'ai un bout pour ça
c'est le mot gestion
non pas qu'il faille la plus politique
la politique c'est autre chose que la
gestion de l'état alors la politique
telle que vous la décrivez est une forme
d'utopie dont je ne dirais pas que c'est
une utopie parce que elle repose sur une
manière extrêmement précise du monde tel
qu'il est une utopie c'est quelque chose
qui décrit al avance comme tous fait un
monde radieux
c'est pas du tout ça que j'ai en tête ce
que j'ai en tête c'est sur la base de
l'analyse d'une société dans le don
levis constitutif est décelable à savoir
l'appropriation privée de l'écrasante
majorité des ressources de la terre et
les conséquences de cette appropriation
privée c'est la loi du profit comme loi
fondamentale du développement de
l'économie se vit ce qui est repérée
depuis pas très longtemps mais qui
repéraient maintenant consommer une
société qui se tire de ce vie cela sera
une expérience difficile mais il faut
bien avoir en tête que autre chose est
possible
c'est sur la lisière du prêt de
l'impossible que la société il faut bien
avoir en tête l'idée que autre chose est
possible pour le faire sinon et bien si
vous déclarez comme c'est la propagande
massive et constante vous ne fait que
répéter la propagande général que c'est
impossible
comme a dit comme l'a dit ça tu cher la
toute première no no other solution
ok si vous êtes là dedans bombe et gérer
le monde comme il ment mais c'est aussi
une propagande de dire qu autre chose
est possible
dire autre chose est possible c'est un
faire une description précise de la
situation actuelle de repérer les forces
éventuel ti peuvent transformer la
lisière entre possible est impossible et
ça c'est faire de la politique et le
coeur de cette politique à vrai dire
comme le montre mai 68 donc c'est
l'élément la leçon principale c'est
quand même que un certain nombre
d'intellectuels jeunes et cetera aille
se mêler des affaires du peuple
fondamental de cette planète est quand
même composé que le regrette 2 milliards
de pauvres alors comment expliquez vous
que la révolte à la révolution ne
prennent pas il ya des tentatives de
révolte aujourd'hui en france et ces
derniers mois dans l'actualité elle
était nombreuse je parlais des blocages
des universités la défense de la zad les
violences des black blocks on a beaucoup
critiqué à ce titre autant de phénomènes
qui ont lieu et qui retombe
mais évidemment pas opprimer 68 derrière
d'orbey absolue absolument le le le
chemin de la politique nouvelle sur un
chemin long et tortueux regarder que ce
cas était le long chemin dans notre
occident de l'idée démocratique
1 l'idée démocratique que vous trouvez
aujourd'hui comme parfaitement
convenable installé que c'est un combien
de temps at-elle be et donc combien
d'expérience qui avait échoué s'est elle
produite au cours des siècles
nous avons encore là la monarchie en
france au début du 19e siècle
c'est une échelle temporelle minuscule
tandis que et donc l'idée démocratique
elle même a suivi un chemin tortueux et
pendant très longtemps elle était
considérée comme impossible
il est évident que le communisme
aujourd'hui c'est exactement
l'équivalent de la démocratie au 18e au
xviie siècle aux 19 chaînes
est ce qu'il faut garder le mode
communisme sapa trouve à trouver un
autre terme un autre volet le mot le mot
le mot le mot aux nouveaux démocratie
même le mot république était traîné dans
la boue pendant des pendant des siècles
au mieux comme une utopie criminels
force que luther écrit sur les vols de
paysans et sur ce qui a été dit sur la
révolution française dans toute la
période de la restauration s'étaient
présentés comme une boucherie sanglante
exactement comme on présente stalino
journée et et ça c'est nécessaire
l'adversaire lorsqu'il a réussi à
vaincre une tentative voilà d'écrire
sous des traits et ses serments
monstrueux mais ça c'est pas le sait pas
l'essentiel ce n'est pas le plus
important le plus important c'est de
savoir que l'acharnement la continuité
la perspective à long terme sont des
nécessités inéluctable de la politique
contemporaine sur nés dans le court
terme on est forcément dans l'ordre dans
l'ordre établi
le philosophe pierre manent va nous
rejoindre pour continuer cette
discussion il ne défend pas forcément
l'idée de révolte comme vous le faites
ni même le règne de l'idée semble-t-il
mais avant de l'accueillir voici raymond
aron qui propose sa définition de ce
qu'est la bonne politique bien sûr les
horreurs n'ont pas disparu on se bat
pour une terre qu'habite des populations
différentes que chacune revendique pour
elle-même on se bat parce qu'on a la
couleur de la peau différente
on se bat parce que l'on croit à
d'autres dieux mais lentement mais
peut-être sûrement s'insinue dans la
conscience des hommes le sens de la
solidarité de leur destin la volonté de
réaliser les mêmes rêves qui est de
transformer cette terre vallée de larmes
et de misère en un lieu où les hommes
pourrait vivre dignement
je crains que vous ne trouviez dans ces
propos une espèce de sagesse étroites
c'est médiocre
je sais tout ce que l'on pu dire contre
ses perspectives d'optimisme mais je
sais aussi que lorsque la paix est
devenue conforme à la raison on n'a pas
le droit de désespérer et que
l'espérance est justifié bonjour
permanent bonjour merci me rejoindre sur
la plateau livret vous une chose à dire
pour vous présenter que vous avez été
l'assistant de raymond aron c'est un
cadeau que je reçois comme feld d'écouté
raymond aron c'est un texte que je ne
connaissais pas dans un registre où je
ne le connaissais pas c'était en 1959
dans l'émission la fin du monde de
françois chalais il est vrai que ici
raymond aron exprime une idée un souhait
celui de voir les individus sur terre
vivre dignement et le summum même de lui
même s'il anticipe le reproche qu'on
pourrait lui faire reproche d'optimisme
de sagesse étroite est médiocre et
pourtant on a ici l'expression d'un type
de politique pour reprendre la
distinction vous faisiez alain badiou
qui est celui du côté de l'idée et non
pas du côté de l'agencement des faits
c'est une idée qui est quand même porté
par un mouvement social par changement
de
comment dire la composition psychique
des êtres humains la reconnaissance de
l'unité de l'espèce humaine
tout cela suppose tout ça suppose un
travail intellectuel et moral qui a
précédé ce sentiment de l'unité humaine
donc voilà est-ce que vous rejoignez
cette distinction entre une politique
qui se fait au nom d'une idée la vraie
politique selon alain badiou et la
politique de gestion jusqu'au vermont
aaron appartient de raids mais c'est sa
voix la deuxième catégorie qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
c'est d'abord l'être humain n'est jamais
sans idée même les politiques les plus
étroites repose en réalité sur des idées
simplement des idées in examiner donc ce
serait la première remarque je ferai
ensuite quelles sont les bonnes idées
au nom de quelle bonne idée il faut
conduire une politique ça c'est une
vraie question est en effet une
politique raisonnable
en tout cas une bonne politique doit
être capable de s'expliquer et je crois
que c'est un des grands argumentaire en
faveur de notre régime libéral
démocratique tel qu'il a été développé à
la fin du xviiie au début du 19e siècle
un argument d'ailleurs défendu
particulièrement brillamment par guizhou
ce n'est pas celui que l'on attendrait
sur ce terrain mais précisément que la
bonne politique devait pouvoir être
argumenté défendu rationnellement
raisonnablement et que l'europe devait
donc supposer que l'interlocuteur était
capable d'entendre des raisons rendre
raison de ces reconduites rendre raison
de ses projets voilà un ressort d'une
bonne politique ce n'est pas suffisant
mais voilà un des conditions d'une bonne
politique sur laquelle vous reste en
principe préalable sur lequel nous
pouvons nous accorder
et alors quelle est votre position sur
la révolte vous avez entendu ce que
disait alain badiou est ce que vous
pensez que nous avons raison de nous
révolter
aujourd'hui je pense pas que j'aurai
j'aurais donné un de mes ouvrages le
coût pour titre une maxime du président
mode c'est tout mais c'est une remarque
en passant
qu'ils s'adressent à votre voisin de
droite mal placé aujourd'hui sur le fait
on n'est ce pas on a raison de se
révolter
je dirais on a parfois raison de se
révolter tout dépend mais alain badiou
l'a précisé en réponse à votre question
tout dépend des circonstances des
finalités des conditions évidemment
c'est une maxime qui comme telle ne peut
pas nous guider beaucoup je préfère
faire une remarque sur la notion de
révolte et la notion d'indignation dont
il a été question
les grecs précisément platon en
particulier auquel alain badiou a fait
de nombreuses références et qui joue un
grand rôle dans son oeuvre
les grecs ont été très sensibles à ce
ressort de la vie humaine qu'est
l'indignation la colère et l'indignation
au nom de la justice
êtes-vous plutôt de l'injustice qui nous
est faite et qui nous qui suscite notre
indignation et notre colère est à coup
sûr c'est un des grands ressorts de la
vue maintenant des grands ressorts sans
lequel la vie humaine est inconcevable
et en même temps c'est un ressort très
dangereux c'est très dangereux
les grecs ont sont très sensibles à
l'ambivalence de ce ressort de cette la
colère qui rien ne rien ne conduit plus
rien ne conduit plus facilement et plus
vite à l'injustice que le sentiment
d'injustice qui vous est fait
et donc voilà la raison pour laquelle je
serai moins universellement moins
spontanément - préalablement si je peux
dire favorables à l'idée de révolte en
tout cas ces mêmes convives mais si je
vous ai bien lui l'idée de rêve elle
n'est pas présente dans votre travail
d'être révolte comme tel nom oui mais
l'idée d'une action humaine ordonné à
une idée du bien ou du meilleur peut
conduire dans certaines circonstances à
une révolte la révolte fait partie des
comportements humains possibles et dans
certaines circonstances légitime et même
dans certaines circonstances nécessaire
simplement je ne la mettrait
certainement pas au premier plan de la
façon dont je j'approche notre existence
commune alain badiou est ce que vous
avez vu de raymond aron vous
vous réconcilier avec lui oui mais je
voudrais dire ça tiendra lieu de
réconciliation peut-être l'air d'accord
que j'ai avec vous d'accord paradoxale
si je puis dire d'abord premièrement
dans le livre dont que que j'ai lu vous
passez d'une certaine critique de l'idée
des droits de l'homme nous faut parler
du dernier livre de saint-louis la loi
naturelle et les droits de la absolument
comme de l'idée que l'universalité de
cette maxime pose des questions or
toutes discussions très serrées sur le
rapport entre sa la loi le droit etc
mais finalement vous dit une chose qui
m'a avec le juge ne trouverait pas
d'accord vous dit que finalement la
liberté des engagements est une chose
importante mais que la question de
savoir ce qu'ils valent et dire qu'elle
a le protocole d'évaluation des
finalités poursuivies et en particulier
vous dites de savoir s'ils sont juste ou
s'ils servent le bien commun et en
définitive la question ultime
or cette question ultime je la partage
politique et en particulier le fait que
en effet la négation coléreuse ne peut
pas servir de levier fondamental unique
de la politique c'est impossible
finalement on en revient toujours quand
même à l'évaluation
c'est à dire y at il derrière cette
politique une idée fiable de la justice
et du bien commun
alors pour bien comprendre ce dont il
est question dans votre dernier livre
observa non vous voulez réhabiliter la
notion de loi naturelle et c'est une
manière pour vous de d'interroger voire
même d'attaquer les fondements de la vie
politique moderne est ce que vous
appelez la pensée des droits de l'homme
quel est le problème avec les droits de
l'homme aujourd'hui c'est un problème
qui a été identifiée dès le début de la
proposition des droits de l'homme à la
fin du xviiie au début du 19e siècle
c'est que la notion des droits de
l'homme est une notion de l'homme
dissocier n'est ce pas parce parler des
droits de l'homme séparée de l'homme
l'idée simplement que chacun dans des
sens on est avec des droits égaux
c'est une idée très très noble très
attirants et qui a produit beaucoup de
bons effets dans sa traduction effective
et en même temps c'est une idée étrange
parce que l'homme se trouve toujours
dans une société particulière avec des
institutions particulière des pouvoirs
constitués et il ne se trouve jamais
dans cette condition originel où les
droits seraient traités go et les hommes
seraient séparés donc là la politique
moderne s'est construite pour une part
s'est construite sur la base d'une idée
apolitique asocial et même anti
politique même anti sociale c'est
pourquoi est celle du droit non pas du
droit des droits de l'homme parce que le
droit est toujours le droit d'une
société constituée le droit est toujours
le droit nouveau site est constitué dont
le droit suppose la sociabilité humaine
le droit suppose une social une société
déjà fait l invasion
oui mais j'approuve paradoxalement
j'approuve cette louis parce que la
vérité c'est que dans un monde réel les
hommes ne naissent pas justement libres
égaux
donc tout le problème de savoir quelle
est la figure de trajectoire qui conduit
d'une situation effective ou les hommes
en réalité ne naissent pas libre et
encore moins égaux ce que ce qui serait
la réalisation effective donc dans des
sociétés effectivement existantes de la
maxime selon lequel ils sont libres et
égaux voilà et la politique elle ne
consiste pas à répéter que les hommes
ont les mêmes droits qui sont libres et
égaux puisque de toute façon c'est une
maxime remarqua mais que c'est tout à
fait inexact que les hommes dans leur le
monde d'aujourd'hui n'ont absolument pas
les mêmes possibilités de liberté est
encore bien moins l'égalité des
situations et des fortunes et si on veut
passer un monde dans lequel cette maxime
devienne réelle mais il faut se révolter
contre le monde d'aujourd'hui il faut le
transformer de façon radicale dans ses
fondements mêmes et à ce moment là on
réalisera la maxime parce que le tout ça
repose quand même sur je leur ai dit
votre propos naturellement tout ça ce
est aujourd'hui dans une figure d'
imposture
la répétition selon lequel
l'homme naissent libres et égaux se
heurte au fait que ce n'est pas vrai
nous a parlé de l'importance de l'idée
n'est ce pas une idée à poursuivre une
idée que l'on aimerait voir advenir
révélant faut pas dire que j'ai annoncée
alors il faut pas dire que les hommes
naissent libres et égaux il faut
commencer par dire que les hommes
naissent dans des conditions qui sont
souvent non libres et inégale alors et
après il faut dire que la maxime c'est
une société égalitaire et vous voyez mec
ça transforme complètement la logique la
logique de l'assomption des droits de
l'homme et la propagande qui est fait
autour qui consiste quand même un match
qu'est précisément ce qui nous sépare de
la réalisation de cette maxime et vous
êtes tous les deux finalement émissaire
d'une période marquée par une forme
d'idéologie très stable qui se vivait
des idéologies qui se vivait comme comme
autant de vérités en guerre contre
d'autres vérités le monde dans lequel
nous vivons est bien différent et c'est
encore un monde où l'idéologie pas avoir
une place qu'elle soit communiste
qu'elle soit d'ordre conservateur c'est
finalement il ya une forme de
conservatisme à se battre la même
idéologie toute sa vie aussi
alain badiou je pense que ce que
l'histoire montre c'est que il y a des
périodes de d'effervescence créatrice de
révolte de révolution de réajustement
des paramètres
une affirmation nouvelle de ce que
signifie la notion de droits d'égalité
etc
il ya des périodes de ce genre il ya des
périodes de restauration conservatrice
et ça c'est la pulsion de l'histoire et
le thread d'accord là encore de façon
limitée avec vous parce que je pense en
effet que l'analyse effective de ce que
nos ancêtres appelait la situation
concrète est une condition sinequanone
des propositions et de fait je suis
d'accord au fait qu'il paye encore un
emballement on pourrait dire de manière
générale finalement ultra gauchistes
comme ça dont les effets ravageurs
nous les connaissons maintenant mais à
quoi ça tient ça tient au fait que si
vous faites des propositions qui ne sont
normés ni par une idée effectivement
enracinée dans la situation ni par une
considération très rapproché de ce que
cette situation rend possible ou
impossible
vous allez en effet finalement utilisé
de violences inutiles seul suis d'accord
avec ce point
donc le bilan que nous devons tirer des
révolutions du xxème siècle ce n'est pas
du tout la renonciation
au but stratégique d'une transformation
de l'humanité de son détachement de la
souveraineté la propriété privée etc
enfin de tous les trois caractéristiques
au fond qui sont encore celles du monde
néolithique 1 propriété privée famille
et à aller au delà de sa sortir de cela
c'est au fond le vecteur de l'idée
communiste
eh beh je suis d'accord de dire que pour
autant que ça doit devenir une politique
ça doit être tout à fait interne à des
périodes qui peuvent être des périodes
extrêmement difficile c'est encore une
grille de lecture valide aujourd'hui le
monde a changé le nom n'est plus celui
de raymond aron le monde est très
différent l'idéologie est complètement
différente les gens qui se révoltent le
font pour des mais pour des motifs très
différents
c'est une question d'échelle
personnellement je trouve que le monde
ait très peu différent depuis les
pharaons d'égypte vous voyez que c'est
pour ça que c'est pour ça que la sortie
de ce monde là que d'ailleurs marx
appelait très légitimement encore une
préhistoire
ces démarches on sait que tout ça
c'était encore de la préhistoire et que
l'histoire réelle de l'humanité était à
venir donc si de sortir d'une longue
préhistoire dont la formule moderne est
en effet tout à fait nouvelle par
ailleurs d'un transformer les paramètres
bien il faut pas s'attendre à ce que une
révolution au sens limité du terme c'est
à dire la prise du pouvoir quelque part
par des forces de matrix va trancher ce
problème est une autre c'est une autre
temporalité dont il s'agît permanence à
cette question il me semble qu'il ya
dans la dernière période un grand
changement mais un changement que je
dirais largement limité à l'europe
drogue et krebs la terre de naissance de
tout ce dont nous parlons aujourd'hui
des idéologies et des mouvements sociaux
cette ce changement c'est
l'affaiblissement de ce complexe
d'énergie sociale qui se déployaient
dans la nation ou dans les nations et
entre les classes tout ce dont nous
parlons c'est ce sont des mouvements
intellectuels des mouvements sociaux des
mouvements affectif qui se sont déployés
dans les nations européennes moderne
confronté à la lutte des classes et la
lutte des classes et la lutte des
nations qui ont été les grands ressorts
de ce te ce déploiement est une des
raisons pour lesquelles je considérais
avec avec disons au moins scepticisme la
perspective communiste c'est que en
dehors des effets du communisme réel que
nous laissons côté c'est que l'idée
commune l'idée révolutionnaire telle
qu'elle a pris forme au xxème siècle au
19e siècle que nous connaissons reposer
sur ce conditionnement social historique
de des énergies social en quelque sorte
tendue et concentrée dans le complexe
nation classe aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on
assiste à cet affaiblissement
considérable des nations en europe and
europe et dans le reste du monde
affaiblissement concert des nations et
affaiblissements aussi de la classe
comme principe d'associations et 2 et
d'orientation dans le monde
il y a beaucoup de deux conditions
comment dire socialement
désavantagés je ne sais pas comment
d'aujourd'hui de conditions misérables
mais il n'y a plus cette concentration
du peuple social en quelque sorte cette
concentration du prolétariat dans les
usines dans l'est dans les professions
donc et les nations et les classes se
sont considérablement affaibli est donc
un des grands principes
un des grands principes à la fois
d'orientation et de d une grande source
d'énergie social du mouvement du 19e
siècle du xxème siècle en europe
c'est aujourd'hui largement étiolé est
affaiblie et notre la perplexité donc
c'est une perplexité générale
pourquoi ils se retrouvent tous sur la
même politique parce que ils ne savent
ils n'ont plus d'autres éléments
d'orientation que cette que ce réseau
mondial qui semble s'imposer à nous qui
au moins qu'ils nous donnent comme seul
comme seule feuille de route
adaptez-vous mais nous n'avons plus en
nous mêmes ni dans nos nations ni dans
nos classes en nous mêmes un principe
d'orientation qui vient de nous en
principe d'orientation intérieure ce qui
change considérablement la donne ce qui
change la donne et qui rend notre alors
je dirais qu'il faut être précis et
spécifiques ce que tout ce que vous
dites pourrait s'appliquer à n'importe
quelle époque en réalité non
l'un et l'autre non je veux dire quand
quand par exemple
l'appartenance nationale était
évidemment le fait majeur de la d'une
vie humaine
quand masquant quand j'étais petit mais
l'évidence d'être français et être
français remplissent et suffisamment si
j'ose dire mon sentiment
d'identification collective bon camp
cette référence n'a plus l'évidence
qu'elle avait quelque chose de
profondément changé quand on cherche le
peuple n'est ce pas quand la classe la
classe qui avait dont les dans les
mouvements dans les mouvements avait
donné son som talbot en quelque sorte à
l'histoire l'histoire sociale poésie
moderne on ne la retrouve plus ou à les
disperser
eh bien ça change profondément les
conditions dans lesquelles nous vivons
et je crois que là la perplexité
générale dans laquelle nous sommes est
lié
à cette disparition de ces grandes
références sociales politiques et
inséparablement intellectuelle ou
idéologique el ahmadi est le sens de
cela est très simple il faut cesser de
voir les sourdes à l'échelle de l'europe
aujourd'hui les propos et les lieux de
possible transformation radicale du
monde se trouve là où précisément un
certain nombre d éléments que vous
mentionnez sont tout-à-fait subsistent
en laquelle il croyait que bien que en
chine la catégorie de la nation la
catégorie d'ouvriers la catégorie de
lutte des classes est extrêmement vivace
et l'est aussi en inde et dans les
régions
actuellement il n'y a jamais eu autant
d'ouvriers dans le monde
statistiquement il n'a jamais eu autant
d'ouvriers dans le monde simplement
évidemment entre 50 et 60% ces souris
sont en asie et les nations d'asie
elles sont très affirmative quant à leur
être propre
donc en réalité c'est l'idée de mark
kelly des justes les la perspective pour
les tares yens doit s'installer dans
l'échelle internationale et s'il ne
s'installe pas dans l'échelle
internationale soit elle rencontrera le
mât sionisme comme un objectif majeur
soit elle rencontrera les conditions
sociales d'un ensemble restreint comme
rien ne comporte en plus en effet les
facteurs que vous disiez un facteur
décisif de l'histoire française récente
a été sa désindustrialisation massive la
banlieue parisienne ne ressemble
absolument plus à ce qu'elles étaient ya
seulement 10 ou 20 ans mais les
prolétaires n'ont pas disparu les
prolétaires sont devenus plus
internationaux je puis dire qu'ils n'ont
jamais été je vais demander à l'un et à
l'autre d'apporter vos livres de chevet
trois livres qui ont compté pour vous
qui sont sur votre table de nuit en ce
moment si ce n'est aujourd'hui elle en
mai duquel son livre que vous avez
apporté
et bien je vous ai apporté d'abord
platon le show fist bon ça c'est assez
naturel point philosophe n'a rien
d'exotique si je puis dire et j'ai pris
celui là parce que j'y vois la naissance
véritable de la pensée dialectique henri
tu es dans le sophiste la question clé
c'est la question y at il une existence
est une activité d'une honnête donc de
la négation et cette idée finalement qui
ensuite transité dans toute l'histoire
de la philosophie qui a été magnifié par
eagle est un courant qui alimente ma
pensée et donc le sophiste est un de mes
livres de chevet voilà pour le premier
bien le second tout à fait différent
c'est l'idiot elle de ski parce que là
je pense que c'est l'intensité du
romanesque à l'état pur désir c'est de
le monde immense roman pendant tout le
19ème et le 20ème siècle mais celui là
je le trouve dans le croisement qu'il
opère entre santé folie entre l'individu
isolé les structures du monde dans les
aventures amoureuses dramatique s'est
taillé un entrelacement de tout ça que
l'une forte tout à fait particulière et
donc c'était un de mes romans préférés
vrai ans et le troisième sur le rivage
des syrtes de 2,2 des grappes raisons
tout à fait différente par ailleurs un
beau libre mais je trouve que c'est un
livre qui parle déjà de façon anticipée
de notre situation actuelle sur un point
particulier qui confondent rivage des
syrtes décrit précisément quelque chose
de proche de ce que votre nom vous
parliez à savoir une société qui ne sait
plus très bien ce qu'elle est qui est
déstructurée du point de vue de ses
contradictions qui est en repos à la
fois un peu endormi et complètement
transformé et dans laquelle petit à
petit l'idée s'impose qu'il faudra qu'il
se passe quelque chose n'importe quoi
mais qu'il faudrait en simplement qu'il
se passe quelque chose
un événement et là ça va être une guerre
et général décrit admirablement le le
cheminement de cette passion pour
l'événement à l'intérieur d'une région
où une s'empêche plus haut que
l'événement est un temps qui vous
dessert votre philosophie alain badiou
permanent quels livres avez vous apporté
je suis très intimidé par les choix dans
la bad you're c'est pas une compétition
mais les auteurs que je vais apporter
vont être eux aussi intimidée par leur
proximité avec platon et plateaux
dostoïevski un livre de mon collègue gil
delannoi la nation contre le
nationalisme car c'est un des grands
enjeux du débat actuel que cette
question de la nation en tout cas je
crois que c'est un des grands enjeux qui
est cette forme politique qui est
aujourd'hui regardait presse
exclusivement sous laon du nationalisme
n'est ce pas comme si le seul support de
la nation était le nationalisme et gil
delannoi montre de façon à la fois très
sobre très savante aussi à quel point
c'est une vue traductrice d'une forme
politique qui apportait malgré tout
parfois pour le pire mais souvent pour
le meilleur en tout cas pour le bon
disons le la civilisation européenne et
le développement politique de l'europe
l'om livre blanc de machiavel oui
nicolau maximo essai sur l'art d'écrire
de machiavel par un autre mes collègues
et amis philippe benetton qui est
admirable connaisseur de machiavel à la
suite de leo strauss qui vous savez a
montré à quel point
là la prose de machiavel si limpide si
frappant aussi éblouissante et est en
même temps un champ de mines et de ruse
et il
philippe benetton nous guide dans ce
champ de mines et de ruse avec une
grande compétence et enfin puisque c'est
1917 1918 un livre de boris creed chef
qui vers la catastrophe le russe lettre
de petrograd au journal l'humanité aux
éditions de fallois
c'est un ce sont des textes écrits au
jour le jour par ce virus sur le
développement des événements avec
beaucoup de sobriété évidemment de
compétences puis s'il est aux premières
loges il envoie il envoie ses lettres au
journal l'humanité qui en qui publiera
les premiers les premières et qui
ensuite ne cessera de les publier et qui
fait apparaître tout de même dès le
début du mouvement bolchevique à la fois
cette brutalité 7 disons propension au
mensonge et au cynisme qui va
caractériser la suite du mouvement
communiste en russie et ailleurs
merci à l'un et à l'autre vous avez
confirmé aujourd'hui une forme
d'hypothèse qui est que lorsqu'on
présente deux personnes comme étant
d'accord sur rien
elles sont systématiquement d'accord sur
tous les points on a raison de se
révolter c'est votre livre chez fayard
pierre manent la loi naturelle et les
droits de l'homme aux éditions puf on se
quitte avec une chanson comme chaque
semaine
ici une chanson sur la liberté peut-être
une forme de révolte i want to break
free de queen
[Musique]
carnot s'étaient livrés vous avec le
concours du centre national du livre
[Musique]